[Music]
by 2050 there are going to be almost 10
billion of us living on this planet and
all of us will need food to survive if
we don't change anything and we will go
on in the way we are now consuming our
food then the next 40 years we need to
produce as much food as we did over the
last eight thousand years and that's
that's a huge challenge
agriculture is the largest source of non
co2 greenhouse gas emissions and along
with climate change and urbanization the
resources that we need to feed everyone
things like space and water are becoming
harder to find that's why scientists and
farmers across the world are finding new
ways to help us and our planet thrive so
[Music]
you're now in the central area of the
Netherlands and within this area we have
many different institutes and industries
that are focusing on the big challenges
in food
we like to study things in nature try to
learn from things in nature and try to
transfer this into solutions that can
improve the quality of life of humankind
wageningen university is known as the
Silicon Valley of Agriculture students
and researchers from more than 100
countries work here in vast greenhouses
and labs to determine the future of our
food and how we'll grow it a green
revolution in the 20th century started
by a guy named Borlaug and he was a
plant breeder and what I like about the
story is that the guy got the Nobel
Prize for Peace not for science but for
peace and the reason was that he came up
with new cultivars of wheat that were
able to produce more per plant and in
that way he could offer a solution for
the hunger that was quite important at
that time in Asia and in Africa the bad
thing was of course that the new
cultivars also needed a lot of
fertilizers a lot of pesticides and
that's the reason why I think we need a
new green revolution we need to produce
more per square meter but at the same
time we need to use less fertilizer or
less energy less water so more with less
and better is really a summary of our
research programs along with the
driverless tractors and agroforestry
being developed here at the university's
research farm the next Green Revolution
could rely on optimizing the most
fundamental process in every plant
photosynthesis all life depends now on
photosynthesis so it's an essential
building block of life for a long time
people thought that this could not be
changed anymore they thought this is a
fixed thing it already exists for about
two billion years so a very long time
people thought evolution would have
taken care of this and now it looks like
it's not
the team created a robot filled with
cameras that can image plants while they
photosynthesize using a property called
chlorophyll fluorescence by examining
photosynthesis at the DNA level they
identified natural genetic variations in
the way plants handle light that data
can be used to breed crops which are
almost 50% better at the process not
only could that double yields but the
optimized plants will be more efficient
with resources like water and nutrients
in the soil so what the Green Revolution
taught us how it by changing the
architecture of plants we could harvest
more the plant and that's probably saved
the humanity from a lot of trouble now
this new step in looking at
photosynthesis could mean the same so if
we can improve with only a few
percentages for the synthesis we would
also be able to improve plant
productivity and if he can do that in a
sustainable and durable way for a long
term and making it available to a lot of
people by just increasing one trades and
would give us a tremendous boost forward
on the other side of the world in China
improving food production to feed its
1.4 billion people is already an urgent
problem to solve support lines and oh
boy - say chunko medicinal ones of which
the Buddha has a station show it's hot
so here's a woman who was secretary to
the showing TV season function is over
mission didn't she adopt an authority
dozen known injections
this small-scale peasant economy means
lower production at a higher cost and
combined with food safety and
sustainability challenges
this creates major problems for the
country's agriculture industry dr. Lee
Shao hua is the research director at sun
on sino science a joint venture between
the chinese academy of science and a
local led maker in 2016 they built this
factory made up of eight three-story
buildings to grow medicinal plants and
vegetables this one building covers just
under an acre of land but provides 1.8
tons of produce every single day so with
an idea Peppa your since help me tell
you okay this is real or is it him to
pursue the journey wait you're saying
something you should we came here with
me anyway so so she talks about their
secret a modular planting system made up
of 1 meter square boards which contain
lighting and storage for a nutrient
solution the board's easily slot
together and can be replaced quickly if
they break I don't see them anyway there
you go just so someone quit out for the
junkie you know what mission the
division they seem to be thrown out of
order so it has a city kid thank you
didn't I just say one really - yeah what
do we mean ha
guns on crisis passes you don't even
know go and the only thing your mother
shall have an inner go ng you can enjoy
begin from fingers or one more single
solution there's no need for pesticides
and the cooling system recycles
evaporated water back to the plants so
that some use over 18 times less than if
they were grown in a field
for now most of the vegetables are sold
at local supermarkets across Fujian
province and one bag of lettuce costs 11
times more than others on the shelf but
the price is likely to get lower as the
technology becomes more widespread when
a delicious topic focuses activities so
hideously the paraffin and she's tiny
Seeger Sundance women pimp little God as
Netanyahu 19% and if you knew she often
Buddha in Israel
solving problems in food production will
also mean that you you are working on
solving issues that affects the whole
earth it's a combination of feeling
responsible for the environment and
feeling responsible for feeding the
growing population
you
you